so yesterday I went to school and I wore
my hair in the afro like this and a lot
of people had a lot of mean things to
say about it
so that made me feel some type of way I
told my mom and she said promise don't
forget who you are and who's you are I
said okay so today I'm gonna go to
school and I'm gonna come back bigger
and better and don't allow anyone steal
your joy don't forgive them that much
power that's so cool that you just you
flipped it you turned it into a positive
you turn it into confidence I love that
how did the kids react anyway back the
next day they're kind of used to it but
some people still were asking like why
are you wearing your hair like that was
like why are you wearing your hair like
that
I love that your video though has
inspired so many people including my
guest
my first guest y'all she is a Golden
Globe award-winning actress and the star
of blackish the last time I saw her she
was singing a moment like this at the
American Music Awards it was awesome say
hello to Tracy on this roster
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this